لطالما كان ظهوره مثيرا للجدل والاسئله
انه يبكيني بريكوجين قائد مجموعه باجنار
على حسابه الرسمي في منصه تيليجرام اطلق
بريكوجين تصريحات في اكثر من اتجاه يقول
ان ما يحدث في اوكرانيا عار يجب على قواته
عدم المشاركه فيه دون توضيح المقصود
بالضبط هل هو طريقه اداره الحرب ام الحرب
نفسها اضاف بريكوجين ان قواته ستبقى في
بيلاروسيا لبعض الوقت وانه سيجعل الجيش
البيلاروسي ثاني اقوى جيش في العالم عقب
كشف قياده الروسيه عن مفاوضات جرت بين
الرئيس الروسي وبريكوجين بعد خمسه ايام من
بدء التمرد ذكرت صحيفه كوميرسنت الروسيه
ان بوتين قدم اقتراحا لمقاتلي باجنار
بتعيين قائد جديد لهم من ضمن المجموعه
نفسها هو اندريت روشيف قائد العمليات
العسكريه لمجموعه فاجنر في سوريا قالت
الصحيفه الروسيه ان الاقتراح الذي تضمن
ايضا التعاقد مع وزاره الدفاع لقاء قبولا
لكن لا يعرف ما حدث لاحقا هل باتت فاجنر
مجموعتين منفصلتين بقيادتين مختلفتين وان
حدث ذلك فعلا فكم بقي من مقاتلين مع
بريكوجين وكم قبل بعرض الرئيس الروسي
الثابت ان ليفاجنر بقياده بريكوجين وجودا
في بيلاروسيا استنادا لحديث قائدها عن
التدريب الذي بدا فعلا قبل ايام ونشرت
صوره وسائل اعلام بيلاروسيه في التسجيل
ايضا ذكر بريكوجين ان مقاتله يستعدون
للتوجه الى افريقيا لا جديد في الوجهه لكن
قد يختلف الانتشار الجغرافي وطبيعه المهام
وكثافه العدد فمقاتلون مجموعه موجودون في
اكثر من دوله افريقيه هذه الصوره نشرها
على منصه تيليجرام يقول انها تظهر تكريم
احد مقاتل المجموعه في جمهوريه افريقيا
الوسطى حيث يقومون هناك بالتدريب وقتال
الارهاب حسب تعبيره لكن الامم المتحده
اتهمت قبل وقت قريب المجموعه وقائدها
بالتسبب في قتل المدنيين ونهب الثروات في
ماله كذلك للم جموعه وجود في ليبيا الى
جانب قوات اللواء المتقاعد خليفه حفتر وفي
السودان تتهم فاغنر بالعمل تحت غطاء شركات
تنقيب عن الذهب وكذلك في مدغشقر وموزمبيق